era of old people so
tom why don't you take the lead with
this you know a lot of things are going
on right now what do you think
is this a should we be paying attention
to why all people are kicking major tail
right now
100 how can you not okay this is the era
of the young person
sorry jen whatever you are all you um
here's the here's the facts okay so yeah
bruce arians win the super bowl
68 years old oldest super bowl coach to
ever win the super bowl i mean belichick
acts grumpier and older but he's
actually younger
you have president trump who is 72 you
have joe biden replacing him he's 78
or staying in sports you have serena
she's 39.
she had a baby like what three four
years ago and she's still dominating
she's in the semifinals at the
australian open you've got lebron
no one can touch him right now lakers
are probably going to win another title
he's 36 you're going tom brady 39. no no
43. yeah 43 tom brady 43 you got dr
fousey who's 80 you got nancy pelosi
who's 80.
i don't think that you could have that
much of a coincidence where that many
older people are dominating now is nancy
pelosi and
fousey doing anything great no that's
called longevity they've just been able
to hold on to the job
but everybody's going to emulate what
these athletes are doing without a doubt
and aryans were supposed to be done i
mean he's he goes against the norm for
every coach in the nfl they're grinding
all day 18 hour days watching film
he's kicking it back in tampa having a
cocktail at the end of the night and it
worked
i think if you're smart enough to
surround yourself with great people
lebron was 35 when the lakers sucked
okay he was still old and they sucked
the next year he got anthony davis he
got other great players
tom brady looked like he was on a
decline until he leaves bill belichick
starts getting his friends in there like
gronk and everybody they win another
super bowl
serena is just an animal i mean she just
refuses to become mediocre
and so there is i think it's a great
sign because i don't think you only want
young people running everything uh
there's something about experience
there's something about
wisdom that you can lead and stuff now
i'm not saying everybody has to do it
but i think it's more of a
more than just a coincidence because you
have nutrition that's improved
fitness you're able to live longer
there's so many things that are working
in the factors
that benefit older people if you still
got the drive
and the hunger and you want it if you
don't you're irrelevant and it doesn't
matter
but you can you can go longer at an
elite level if
you make plans to do it what a great
point what a great opening point tom
adams from the oldest guy on the podcast
i mean you know we're in our 40s you're
in here late 40s
okay careful
great point by tom yeah okay can't
dispute that um
something that i talk about in my
business life settlements life you know
longevity
something that i also talk about in
personal finance is that people are
living longer like the retirement is
being reinvented i just did that
interview with kiyosaki
where traditionally our grandparents or
great grandparent whatever it is at this
point however old you are
you life expectancy in the united states
100 years ago was like 67 years old
right now life expectancy is easily into
your 80s if you take care of yourself
obviously you know these days with covet
pre-existing conditions not taking care
of
yourself
but you could live to 90 100 no problem
in the united states of america these
days if you just take care of yourself
right so overall as a country we are
reinventing longevity
what do all these guys that you said are
living longer have in common you said
you said experience wisdom nutrition
drive what else do they have they have
talent around them i think which helps
talent
they can afford like a serena williams
and a tom brady they can afford the
millions of dollars it takes to be at
that
level they have it with trainers okay so
there you go so go there
you said it they have they can't afford
what they they can
afford the things that can compete uh
allow them to compete at the highest
level which is the great nutritionist
the personal coach that's very big right
there
you know the you know what's the country
in the world with the longest life
expectancy in the world i'm gonna guess
it's norway or something in europe
monaco yeah eighty-nine and a half good
living out there eighty-nine
because it's the wealthiest country
because it's the wealthiest country in
the world so
you can afford better healthcare you can
afford to go see the doctor so there is
maybe there is some you know correlation
between wealth and health 100 so when
people say wealthy because you know back
in the days in the in the 20s and the
30s when they would make the cartoons of
wealthy people who was it it was the guy
the big bang exactly the railroad guy
that's not the case today anymore it's
changed it's slender it's in shape it's
what a personal
trainer is doing yoga you know if you've
worked hard
that hard to accumulate that type of
wealth don't you want to stay alive to
enjoy it
right and you have that advantage and
you can right now yeah i think the
biggest
reason people die younger is because
they're so hard on their bodies i mean
you're you're reckless with your diet
and things like there's so many ways to
kill
yourself if you want to just the way the
food companies put preservatives in
everything and it's out there if you
want to do it
but you can also take the other route
and really defeat those odds and live
almost as long as you want if you take
care of yourself
and try to be disciplined as much as did
they call it back in the day uh
the gout was called the the the king's
disease or what was it called
oh because only they would all eat red
meat and and wine and you would just
like
deteriorate your entire body in your
existence now we went over tom brady's
regimen the day after the super bowl i
mean the guy is up at 5 30. he doesn't
eat certain foods
works out you know protein shakes he
started training again the other day
training i mean he was drunk [ __ ] after
the super bowl but that's a whole
different topic that felt great but
listen if you're if you're listening to
this and you're
and you got somebody in the family
that's kind of like well i feel like i'm
old i feel like i'm this like they need
to hear
this message what was just said that
needs to be shared with them and say
dad can you go listen to this can you
mom can you go listen to this
because a part of this is as well
attitude i think it's an also an
attitude thing you know
did i tell the story on the podcast
about uh john d rockefeller have we
talked about the rockefeller i got a
little bit of a glitch going on here me
too uh uh it's
one of ours i don't know who it is can
you guys hear it okay it's gone
do we talk about the john d rockefeller
story last time so johnny rockefeller
when he's a little kid he said there's
two things i want to do in life i want
to make a hundred thousand dollars
which in today's money he made 350
billion dollars a hundred thousand
dollars he said he wants to make
50. no no no no no no no he said he
wants to make his eventual wealth when
he died
in today's money with inflation it's 350
billion of today's wealth that's bezos
and musk combined that's rockefeller
when he was a kid he said i want to make
a hundred thousand dollars and i want to
live
live up to 100 years old wow he was born
in 1835 18
1835 you know how old he was when he
died
late 90s maybe 97 and 11 months
at a time where the life expectancy was
39 and a half for a man
39 and a half life expectancy was 39 and
a half in 1835 in
1835 the average life expectancy was 39
and a half
he lived 97 years and 11 months he was
two years and a month away from reaching
that hundred
year old wow that's like at that time
right crazy stuff yep but here's the
question here's a question
today with what we have with today's
rockefeller waking up and you know six
years old 10 years old saying
when i grow up i want to have you know a
trillion dollars or a billion dollars or
whatever it is and i want to live
up to what is that number today i think
the kid's going to say a hundred
i i think i don't think anyone is going
to say i want to live to be 110 because
i don't know how good your life is going
to be but i think
in the past maybe you say 85 90 i'm
going to say what do you think
today today kids being guys i'm actually
curious to know kai i may come to you as
well
what do you think kids being born to
like let's just say a dash
stad right i mean he's got a little
injury right now dash is she's going to
be 12 next week happy early birthday
today
take a eight-year-old kid take a 10 year
old kid driven kid
i'm going to go out there and do this
how old do you think the oldest person
is going to be that's 8
10 12 years old today i can speak for
dash he'll say 13 because there's a 20
stair rail he's going to try to go down
there and he'll probably knock himself
out well there was an article
it was a cover story i think time
magazine a handful of years ago
that babies being born today are going
to live to age 130 150. something crazy
like that i don't know like yeah you
think
it's capable it's possible that some
people may look 150 i do and here's why
because look how medicine is advancing
look at the technology
when we start really figuring out some
of these diseases cancer wipes out so
many people what if they got their
handle on cancer
so if you were born with you know
something in your body that
pre-determines that you're gonna get
cancer and you can eliminate that
boom 20 of people are gonna live longer
automatically maybe a whole lot longer
people maybe get away from the heart
disease issues that kill so many people
maybe driving cars they're autonomous
and it's safer on the road
you know there's less drunk drivers i
don't know but i do believe 130 to 150
is a possibility
because nothing surprises me anymore
what do you guys think if you're
watching this
if you think people kids who are 8 10 12
years old today
can live up to 150 years old smash the
thumbs up button
if you think pat you guys are out of
your mind no way in the world they're
going to live maybe 90
100 110. smash the thumbs down button
i'm actually curious to know what the
audience thinks
you hear stories even now i think some
uh uh a nun in france a hundred and ten
years old just beat kovitz 116. she's
never
had 16. 116 beat coveted insane yeah
insane 106 thinking about it she's never
put anything bad into her body probably
right
living on a convent you know she's
praying she's doing her thing you know i
think there's one more factor that's
involved and you kind of mentioned it
it's a motivation what motivates you to
want to live that long and the perfect
example is jeff bezos and the
transformation that he's gone under
physically since he's in the last 10 or
15
years and since he's had the new
girlfriend have you seen he's buffed
he's dressing differently fashion is
important
he seems to have a totally different
motivation and if you have that reason
to
live really long you're going to do all
the little things in your life that will
allow you to but you got to find that
one motivation that'll get you there
i'll say one thing and then i want to
get your opinion um
you talked about motivation which we
talked about we talked about attitude
uh you know you talked about reinventing
yourself
rediscovering re-energizing
re-everything reinvigorating yeah
you know to the 40-year-olds are out
there i have friends who are 40.
and they're like oh i've got two kids
i've already done what i had to do i'm
getting old i'm like bro you're freaking
40.
yeah i'm 40. i'm a man remember you ever
seen that before
what are you talking like i've already
i'm too old 40 bro
there's a list of people who completely
started companies after the age of 40.
40 is nothing these days
moving forward let's say you're in your
60s i'll give you two tales
my stepdad is in his late 60s complete
mess has given up on life
he's his health is horrible listening to
this he's not listening
he's a complete mess i have my uncle
who's happy he's giving you a hard time
you're going to be alright he's trying
to motivate you i promise
you he's given up no motivation not
reinventing himself
i'm 68 years old nothing uh yeah i have
my uncle who's 70
wealthy guy works out every day takes
care of himself
constantly coming up with business
that's ross's dad
complete stud same age so this has
talked about
motivation that talks about attitude
yeah so
i'll know when i'm getting old so udonis
haslam he's the
the long you know i played against him
in high school he's sitting on the end
of the yeah for real
yeah in miami he's 40 years old now
i played against man he's still in the
league sitting at the end of the bench
on the miami heat so and i've known the
guy like off and on for
20 freaking years now so when i see him
at games i used to go to the games it's
always like a head nod like a respect
like keep doing your thing
he's still there doing his thing 40
years ago cheap coach and you've got
cheap coach millions it's a cheap coach
veteran
veterans
younger than kai coming to the league
let me put my hand around you so
40 years old still doing his thing tom
brady 43 uh lebron 37.
i don't know if haslam is in the same
league against but i get what you're
doing no but i'm just saying it's your
friend haslam he likes you
he he's an og in miami we're here in
south florida so here's my question to
you guys
we talked about age to talk about age do
you
want to live to age 100 is that a number
you want to live to
because for me 100 i want to go that
long i would you know
i wouldn't i wouldn't mind living 200.
yeah
it's it's not something i said i'm going
to live to 100 yet i haven't i haven't
said that it's not like
you know i'm going to go out there and
live 200 but i think i wouldn't mind
living 200.
um the the gentleman uh kirk krikorian
yeah 99 98 a hero of yours yeah
he's a small body frame yeah he's a
little dude he's a 5'4 it's a different
story when you're five
six four six four saying that the
littler you are the
that's a better thing of course it is
really you have you have
you have less things that could go back
knees
you know your arms are a mess yeah so no
no we are that's not
listen lebron is six eight so it's not
an excuse i'm making but you know it's
different when it's taller
gotcha versus show but yeah 97 98 years
old 100 you want to get to 100 100 would
be
how about you use that compound yeah i'm
not going to attach a number to it
i just want to keep being healthy and
i'll take it to 120 or bow out at 88 if
i'm not
are you putting pressure under time with
his hands i'm just excited i'm already
going back baby the
the og the veteran so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]